first to give evidence in Prince Harry's
case against mirror group newspapers
Harry and Megan's biographer and a
former journalist at the Sunday Mirror
Dan Evans given a suspended sentence
back in 2014 after admitting illegal
information gathering at the now defunct
news of the world but a journalist
before that at the Sunday Mirror hired
in 2003 to work for then editor Tina
Weaver in court he said it was a badly
kept secret that he was the designated
in-house hacker using burner phones in
her office to keep his work largely out
of sight of The Newsroom
the end denies voicemail Inception at
any of its titles but in court Evan said
he was doing it and had about a 30
success rate claiming that when he was
at the paper in his words he was doing
dodgy stuff on every story
when asked by mgn's legal team if that
was overstating it he said no a lot of
stuff had dodgy goings on insisting it
was so bog standard to do something
dodgy along the line on a story
the Duke of Sussex will be the star
witness in this case but also in court
the author of this book
journalist Omid scoby who when Accused
by mgn lawyers of having a vested
interest in giving evidence said it
would actually make his life more
difficult than he desperately tried to
move away from allegations he's friends
with the couple and that this link
wouldn't help
but he spoke of Hal when he started out
on work experience at the mirrors
entertainment desk in 2002 he heard it's
then editor Piers Morgan asked how
confident the team was in reporting a
story about Kylie Minogue and someone
she was dating he said the conversation
was they had broken up there was
reference made to voicemails and calls
they'd made to each other and this
journalist knew details Piers seemed
reassured by this
evidence from the prince's biographer
ahead of the royal himself coming to
court next month mirror group newspapers
insisting its journalists did nothing
wrong Casey Spencer Sky News